our next speaker is dr. you Longley from
also from Peking University and given
just a moment to set up and he will be
talking about spying on spying know of
no communication by constructing new
genetically encoded fluorescent probes
well is it it's great to be here to see
some old friends and meeting new people
and I really appreciate a organizer in
fact the you know one of my friend our
Comment the design of this tag and he
said it really like looks like I'm a new
groom because of this tag so I I think
we should carry this tradition back to
China so for our speakers we should have
this really nice design but but she also
coming I'm getting fatter and fatter so
I think that Chinese food there is
really good so that you know would be a
big reason for a lot of colleagues in
the states to visit so uh today my talk
is gonna about spying of communication
by constructing new and genetically
encoded efforts and probes as we know
and for a dotted soldiers a nice
introduction in the brain are very
complicated material composed of many
different type of neurons and he just
talked about the dopamine urge neurons
and act accordingly these how the
different interplay is between are these
two systems and to and to execute these
are higher brain functions and we of
course have the single neurons but they
fund microcircuit raise and and laken
atty to regulate different aspect of
higher brain functions so one way to
study the brain function is as daughter
Susan said we can use a good
electrophysiology which give us superior
temporal resolution to detect in MIDI
second resolution how to the transmitter
and we are to the action potential
occurs and how he propagate but the
complicate the camp the camp complex
anatomy actually prevent most of the
irrational physiologies physiologist to
study many neurons at us in town and one
way to to solve these problems by using
optical technique in fact more than ten
years ago when Karen Mesenbourg in Tata
jeans grassman's laughs he designed a
person sensor that is ph-sensitive when
this PhD sensitive first and protein we
attack into the synaptic vesicle which
is acidic upon exocytosis this acidic
environment will meet with the neutral
environment which is outside of the cell
and this correctly target frozen probe
will become neutral and therefore
reporter are the first in changes and it
reflected a transmitter release but
after this ten years still we are still
using a green ones there's no mainly
other color available so when I was a
poster in diction slab at Stanford I
decided to to tackle this problem by
creating more colorful combination of
probes the idea is very simple if we can
generate many different color
combinations then we can use in genetic
ways to pull end into different set of
neurons and the combination of Licata
and simultaneous imaging will allow us
to visualize the synapse transmission in
parallel and therefore hopefully can
help us to decode the complex of the
neuronal circuitry so sue a molecular
genetic evolution studying with em
strawberry developed by my post daughter
advisors brother Roger chance lab and we
introduce mutations into the the frozen
probe and then generate a ph tomato many
because of their chain family or like
fruits the tomato and because it's very
ph-sensitive and as
is similar as the Rogers TD tomato in
terms of the color spectrum as you can
see that in the neutral pH this ph
tomato first and protein is as bright as
the well use egfp but the property is
that is different colors and it's very
PhD sensitive as you can see that by
changing the PhD from low to high that
the first in intensity increase not only
in koh lipe are also in mammalian see o
course using this method then we can
have two colors to allow us
simultaneously imaging different neurons
and this is a comparison with the green
ph tomato target to the synaptic vesicle
and the Reverend and the green when tlie
the perform similarly and because of the
color separation then we can image in
the cell signal transduction if in a sin
cell for example in this case we could
use the genetic encoded calcein
indicator g kel three which is reports
the calcium signal and as you can see if
you stimulate the neurons their
intracellular calcium will rise due to
the activation of voltage-gated calcium
channels not only in the soma which is
shown here but also in your eyes but if
you look at the sift tomato which label
the prisoner terminals in the soma you
don't see too much signal enhance that
is no surprising because there's no
prisoner terminal there is no
transmitter release at least in this
neuron and but in the new right in the
past that lights up by the calcium
signals we can see the prominent signal
enhanced enhancement and that is due to
the calcium activates the transmitter
release showing here so in the same
neurons the color combination will allow
us to look at two different signal at a
symptom and look at their interactions
and separations what about in different
neurons remember now at the beginning of
my talk I think that is more important
if one could image in the listing appt
transmission is the transmitter it is
from a prisoner neuron and a
corresponding Activision
the postsynaptic cells and here is
showing the examples that where we could
look head to the presynaptic neuron muck
in red and the postern avner on muck in
green by the cheek and signal if you
enlarge the signal you can see that
there is a good crease funding of the
prisoner terminal in the way the
postsynaptic cell even touching the
postnet spine and and this signals is
dynamics so if you stimulate a priest in
a neuron which is marked in red and then
look at the post nap to signal in a
green what will happen well in this case
if we will stimulate presynaptic
terminal you can see the transmitter
release from where synaptic boot humps
which is shown on the left of Latino and
a crisp bungling signal if we reach the
stretch hole that you will propagate as
one can see that the enhance of the
causal signal throughout the
postsynaptic neurons and this signal can
be black bye to the mpq X which is a
specific ampere like a receptor blockers
so if you apply latch to the cells where
you can see only seen the low-cost
housing signal originally from the and
I'm d like a receptor because if you
apply to the cocktail of MP cracks and a
PFI this signal is completely gone okay
what about the other application well
this demonstrates in principle that one
could visualize the synapse transmission
all by optical means that is the
pre-snap transmitter release from a red
and a posting up to Activision readout
from the green we in region that this
could be very useful in the in vivo
condition where the circuitry is even
more complicated and and and an
investment is the precursor so this is
the optical reporter and it can easily
cover with the optima optogenetic
approach daughter children was
mentioning about that is the
channelrhodopsin so because we all know
that the channel dobson that can buy
directly absorbing light that you will
allow
let's sail to depolarize so because of
the availability of different flavors of
channel dobson largely done by the work
of daughter Zhang phone and at boylan we
could use the sin color of line to
activate channel dobson but also use
less in light to excite the optical
probe and read out a signal in a
different wavelength then by combining
to the channel channel Dobson with
different flavors of optical reader one
could in principle achieve a platform or
by optical stimulation and recording one
could achieve to control a neuronal
activity and read out whether it's being
activated or inhibited inside us a
nervous system especially in vivo and
this is a proof principle of is
experiment showing in C as you can see
if one could couple to the trend ops
into with the green sensor then if you
want use the direct fuel stimulation
electro stimulation you can see the
crisp on the increase of the signal
reflecting the transmitter release and
is subsequent in internalization of the
transmitter transport but if one pipe
acid attacks are just using light one
can achieve the sensing and importantly
this optical signal can be black
entirely by application of TTX a
specific what educated a sodium channel
inhibitor this demonstrates lateral I
induce stimulation is new is not due to
to the let the rare activation of
channel dobson which is known to be cows
impermeable and we know that the calcium
can trigger transmitter release but the
fetid at TDX can completely brockett
indicating that this transmitter release
requires the generation of action
potential and what the channel adopting
does is simply too deep or as a cell to
reach the threshold
and and similarly one can do that in a
in tight entirely or sucker no color
platform that is using a different
flavor of channel dobson researcher r1
and cover it with a ph tomato base a pro
i was just talking about and this two
optical spectra is separated in a way
that one will not affect each other
therefore in principle one could use two
different kind of line to post stimulate
and record the neuronal activity that is
the transmitter release from the nervous
system and I think that is very useful
especially for in vivo application let
me just digress a little bit talking
about how we envision that week we could
use this in an in vivo system by showing
some of our work in the flight system as
we note that the the flight or factory
system is composed of the several
different layers of input and
integration from peripheral side to the
center in a preferred site the older
receptor neurons just like the human
nose that will receive different odor
inputs that will project into the
antennal lobe into about 50 commander I
and this factory inputs will give
further related to the higher brain
center including the mushroom body and
the lateral harm by different
projections when is by the excitatory
projections from this so-called EPM
projects or I a CT check to both in a
way Latin hall and mushroom body so the
same neurons sends a carbon copy of
signal to national body similar to
humans hippocampus that is important for
linear memory and lateral home will be a
analogous for a middle of or saw to be
important for the in a behavior but
precisely are
excitatory projections there is also
these different projections thats call
em a CT that is sending out from the the
projection neurons sitting in the
ventral side of the antennal lobe is
different from the this I a CT it
directly goes into Latin ha completely
by back by parcel a mushroom body so
this is really interesting if one do
cater the lateral heart that you will
receive two different inputs possible
and antelope but one has a branching out
in a mushroom body and the other ones is
is a completely bypassing that so what
is the function of em I see em acct when
I was a poster in collaboration with the
chin was lab at Stanford along with his
gratitude and young men what we did was
trying to use ways including ironing I
and surgical ways to remove the ma CT
trying to dissect the function of macg
in the factory communication and what we
found was that are using the the
advanced two-photon photo ablation is
ramen we we use the two-photon
microscope to image in a light home hot
neurons and then looking at is calcium
signal the post synaptic response and
the control side of the neuron so we can
also image after image of these two we
lent them at the two photon laser power
a hundred volt and using that two photon
infrared laser to cut specifically the
mset track and then imagina in the same
place what happen at a lateral hop in
the in the photo ablation site as well
as on the control side to see what is
the function of ma CT contribute to the
computation of
that home hall posted at postsynaptic
neuron and what we found interestingly
is if we apply to the mset we see that
there's a posting up to that Horner on
the so-called vlp are neurons has the
enhanced response as you can see here
this is the p4 to the photo ablation
experiment and after the photo ablation
you can see that significant enhancement
of the signal in this part of the Latin
hall in a control site where to the
photo placing did not occurred let us
know too much difference demonstrating a
specificity of this acid and we can
quantify that E is similar for many
different type of norms but this our
response is very specific if you what I
show you previously if you use the food
order and if you cut off the mset you
see the enhancement of this the response
but if you use the sex forum and using
that to to do the same acid what you
found essentially before and after
cutting the EMA HCG there's no
difference of the posting every response
and neural anatomy assuring that this
macet check contains the Kaaba so it's a
inhibitory neurons letter will regulate
this process so the specificity as you
can see across a different group of this
older response indicating that the
inhibitory neurons has a specific row 2
e to inhibit the full related orders but
bypass the sex Foreman in a drosophila
and so the specif the specificity of
this older perception is like while the
Chinese have mentioned many years ago in
more than 2,000 years ago confuses these
that senior in Chinese in English is
food and sex human nature
so we have that distinguish response
philosophy that too they are different
orders either to food or to the formal
so for humans we also have these
different perceptions this give us the
the analogy or maybe that's evolution is
a really evolution conserve in a way
that how the brain interprets different
order signals so while my lab is to try
trying to pursue using our new
generation of photo indicators is trying
to look at the this neural anatomy I was
talking about the ma CT here and I ECT
international hot so how did the
specific inhibition shape this older
response to distinction odors well this
inhibition we know that occurs in Latin
ha in principle you can happen in two
ways one is the way that the carbon read
is directly modulated the EPA neuron in
a prisoner terminal so the transmitter
release get reduced an alternative ways
that the gaba could be act on a post nap
decide to too inhibited integration of
the posting a funeral pyre again a
couple receptors or both so one way to
distinguish you that we don't have a
daughter children's a nice mess of a
carbon fiber recording from the specific
neurons but we envision that we can put
indicators in a prisoner terminal end up
hosting AB terminal from the sales at
the same time if the prison every
inhibition occurs then we will imagine
that the EP and neurotransmitter release
will be inhibited but evil only the
postsynaptic inhibition occurs then we
will see that the prisoner release are
intact and the post nap to inhibition
will dramatically reduce so we have
already generating transgenic flies
using the pre a tomato and similar
proteins in a fly or factory system
so you can see that we are able to use a
lot older stimuli to trigger the preach
has transmitter release detecting by the
optical signal so we are in a process
trying to across this fly with the G can
fly which label the postlab neural in
green to do catch the regulation of this
inhibition at a different locus of the
neurons and we think that that since
strategy can be applied for many
different height of neurons because of
the inhibition occurs widely inside the
brain and in different type of neurons
and finally I want to spend two minutes
to talk about the sins that are going on
in my lap as a sinner Brenda says that
the progress in size depends on many
things but he said that probably depends
on new techniques new discoveries and
new ideas importantly the technique
probably comes first so one of the
important goals of my lab is trying to
develop a developing better sensors for
the neuroscientist not just my lab for
imaging different part of brain and
different activities so we are trying to
develop more sensors not the causal
indicators because there's already
dedicated teens from generating from and
others to develop it we are more focused
on the second messenger neuromodulator
release and activation of neural
moderated receptors and we hope that
using these sensors that we enable us to
look at the sins that none of the new
incentives has able to to seen before
and to illustrate a noble principle of a
neural development and circuitry and
forming and as one example doing our
labs research we found as a interesting
sensor is also PhD sensitive but in
comparison with the traditional sensor
it has a huge stock ship there is the
excitation wavelength and the emission
wavelengths has a hundred and 40
nanometer separation where traditional
EGR P&M
cherry only has 10 to 15 nanometers and
we cut this a frozen protein flamingo
because of its color and is the PhD
dependency in this image as you can see
one can use a simple line to
simultaneously detect the Flamingo red
color and the green color due to this
same excitation spectrum for flamingos
with egfp and also the large stock ships
so the color separation will allow one
to simulate simultaneously detect posts
and we think that this will be useful
for the in vivo imaging and multiplayer
imaging for for example with other
closing indicators and one of this quest
students in my lab for mia has recently
embattled developing new generation
flamingos through her screen she found
that mutations that will have we a PhD
dependency curve letter has a higher
cooperativity between php5 to Phu eight
therefore change in intensity from PHP
528 the signal is increased from a first
generation 10 4 215 for and we hope by
our efforts by direct evolution and
selection we can find more and more
sensors and then we can apply for many
more and neuroscience questions not only
just in our lab and finally I want to
thank my post daughter advisor research
and at Stanford and our collaborators
the chain lab and this is the support
our phone beta and this is part of my
lab which is just about one year old
thank you
questions4 totally see my tie so
wonderful there's no questions can you
tell how there are that your first
application for do you say you have
there the green which is combining with
flamingos and or you also have to muddle
so is there the street will come
together oh you only use I mean to and
what is that wanted you is the flamingo
compared to tomorrow so okay so in
principle we can just use to if I want
to look at the presynaptic neuron and
the postsynaptic neurons which is
actually not that many people in a few
are using may be limited by the
available probes the advantage of the
flamingo as I mentioned briefly but not
indeed here it is because of a meet in
the ref roses so it will avoid a lot of
auto forces generally in a relative UV
to blue range it so in principle you
will have a better signal-to-noise ratio
especially for in vivo application and
if you look at the spectral awfully
flamingo and the egfp and ph tomato i
mentioned in fact least three can be
both apply at a symptom the egfp and the
flamingo has a similar excitation pic so
you can be separate by the emission p
but pH tomato has a distinguished
excitation and emission peak from eg IP
and flamingo so it can also be separate
in both so Shri color is possible is
there only now from our drosophila can
either already use the form eyes yes of
course they are open genetic encode it
is just we are really slow on you know
making the transgenic mice and
and packing the virus so we start
something earlier and fly grow faster
and and also we have some interesting
biological question that we can be
asking to demonstrate prove principle
application of these probes having to be
used yeah not yet could you comment on
the temporal resolution of these
indicators so so this is really a good
point so the temporal resolution of this
indicator is not so great the main
limitation actually if you look at here
the main limitation is the endocytosis
process for this probe our relatives
slow so so therefore the really meeting
step if you want to imogen since a
faster it will has constraints but the
advantage of this probe is because the
optical probe can enable to the parallel
imaging so one wait one can overcome
these difficulties by using the optical
indicators to look at in parallel wait
the neuronal communication by combining
with the electrophysiology such as
illustrating by a daughter children with
superior temporal resolution so then can
one can balance these two to achieve the
best understanding of the neuronal
communication and I think that's just a
fundamental limit of the membrane
dynamics that's not something you can
engineer so the endocytosis process is
known to be temperature dependent so in
flies is you know room temperature is
relatively slowly in vivo you will be
faster than that but still is in the
range of seconds to tens of seconds any
other questions ok if there are no more
questions I'd like to thank both dr. Lee
and all of the speaks for this session
so
chicken